awesome everybody uh welcome to episode
324 of the askgaryvee show this is an
exciting one because worlds collide and
it's a special special day so everybody
watching on live stream I know this will
get posted probably a day later but if
you're watching live tonight 10:00 10:00
p.m. on YouTube mm-hmm and 1:30 in the
morning that's right uh if you're not
Lily once you tell everybody what the
big news is and a little bit about
yourself
sure take the floor for next three
minutes hi my name is Lilly Singh I have
exciting news I am premiering my late
night show my NBC late-night show called
a little late with Lilly Singh it's
after Seth Meyers is 135 a.m. but like
you mentioned because the special days
premiere we're streaming on YouTube
earlier than it premieres on TV at 10:30
p.m. est it's a whole thing it's a whole
thing it's consumed my whole life for
the past couple months is a huge honor
it's the currently the only woman on
network late-night so it's a pretty
right deal there's a very beginning so
let's let's take it all the way back
let's how to do it first of all let's
take it not all the way back let's take
it kind of back to how did this even
happen well I got a phone call saying
hey there's a timeslot that NBC would
love to offer you and I was like wait
what and it took me a really long time
to process this conversation because I
was like they want me to host this or
they want me to be on it once you host
it like myself like they want to be my
show like replace Carson you know they
want your own show like my own show so
many follow-up questions agent calling
you so my manager Galen gonna I'm at
this point you know I've been we're
alright pay me the picture okay this
year it's been eight years of me making
YouTube videos yeah I've done a gang of
other things you know release books have
gone on tours I've done lots of live
performances never dabbled in the world
of traditional TV thus far
so I'm sitting in my office I'm on my
pink blush fabulous couch it is fabulous
it smell of it it's very cute
I'm gonna get a phone call in LA in LA
I'm just going no I liked it I was
wearing a blazer
go ahead really probably sweats but I'm
making it up so it's a blazer and my
agent my manager literally calls and
says random thing NBC wants to talk to
you but a late night show and I remember
being like wait what and so after 30
minutes of confuse
I was like sure I'll do the meeting to
find out more information and I met with
a group of executives white people and
and then they told me they're like we
would love you for the show and I'm not
gonna lie it was a really cool
opportunity but I wanted to take a beat
to think about it because committing to
something of that scale it's like a huge
professional and personal commitment to
make honest mungus yeah so I did like a
month of research actually took a month
to answer them there's two people in
particular I asked for advice one was
Hasan Minhaj and one was Dwayne Johnson
mostly because I have a bad habit of
asking people for advice who don't know
what they're talking about and I wanted
to not do that this time you know I'm
always that person that's like asking
people for relationship advice and
they're single and sad and I'm like
taking advice from them like this time
I'm going to ask people that actually
know what they're talking about love so
they gave me great advice and they both
encouraged me to go through with this I
think my number one concern was I didn't
want to be pigeonholed as a host yeah I
have so many aspirations and and both of
them already in parts of the Hasan's
going to exactly transcends everything
and I really believe that like there is
no pigeonholing
yeah you're willing to break through
doors and windows that's exactly correct
and I think Dwayne said something that
was so smart he said if that was your
concern you would have already been
pigeon-holed as the YouTube girl and
that has never stopped you so that's
what I needed to hear I said yes and
since then my life has been a wild ride
I love it that's so awesome so now let's
take it let's actually I lied I said I'm
moving to you all the way back I'm
actually going backwards okay let's
let's go to the part where you emerged
into the consciousness that led to this
opportunity when did you start producing
for the internet as you see in June 2010
and it was because I was sad truth like
that is the answer I was in the last
year of university I was fulfilling a
major that I had no real passion in
psychology have a psych degree mostly
because that's what my sister did my
parents wanted me to get a degree as a
kid I was so creative whether it was
baking or dancing or rapping I loved
creating and then I think I was
convinced weather was my family or
Society or not that that's not a
realistic
trajectory of life and so I was like
okay time to grow up and get a degree
and get a job and get married and do
this very linear life that everybody
wants me to do um so I got one into a
really dark funk and the last year of my
university career discovered YouTube
thought it was weird as hell I was like
who are these weirdos making videos in
their groups but then you know
eventually just uploaded a video that
was very bad it was a bad video how was
your first bit it was a very awkward
spoken word piece I bought a new blazer
again with the blades I liked the blazer
I don't have a good personalities my
Blazers make up for it okay okay - I'm
great no so I made this video it was a
spoken word piece 70 people watched it
and I was like I'm sorry Monsieur
I'm famous no 70 goddamn people but I
just fell in love with the idea of
creating on my own terms and it made me
happy is very simple I was sad this made
me happy I decided to keep doing this
thing that made me happy
d-roc in post-production for this clip
can we please find the part of crush it
that I wrote in 2008 that basically
describes this exact scenario since now
I'm old and my thesis is are now coming
to life like the I said this over and
over that this is exactly how it was
gonna happen and literally tonight it
happens somebody who created a YouTube
video then hosts a late night show and
that was impossible to believe in 2008
or 9 when the book came out and I
basically am taking full credit thank
you thank you and you know what you get
it you get it there you go I don't know
if you read your contract but there's a
20% big you're actually paying nice yes
so 20% though what is it even less even
less so that happens when did you start
feeling it when did something happen
give me the moment where yeah okay so
that happens that makes sense then was
what was the moment what was the one I
was like miss and I go somewhere or or
the first video that kind of yeah exist
yes so there's a trend called things
girls say do you guys remember that
trend okay so I made a stuffed punjabi
mother say that was my first video to
hit a million views now I was really go
there apologize yeah where where were
your videos coming in at prior to that
buyer to that
so my for contract yeah my first video
hit 10,000
and that was probably like my eighth the
video so took me around eight videos to
ten thousand views which is a lot which
is which is a lot of views for an eighth
video
uh-huh and by the way I'm just gonna
jump in right now for everybody
listening the thing that I talked about
in crush it still to this day and just
to make this valuable for everybody
listening and by the way if you're
watching LinkedIn Facebook put your
phone numbers up and Katy here will be
grabbing the phone numbers we're gonna
do some calls before the show's over so
you can see where the themes are going
here I know a lot of this audience is
gonna have questions for Lily uh - I
think one thing that needs to be talked
about is talent like even the way you
delivered awesome
when you were saying the Blazer thing
like talent is a real equation like
there are people who are gonna get
10,000 views on her 8th video who who
are exactly the people that go on to do
other things there's a very fine line
for everybody of like perseverance you
know like you know there's plenty people
gave up making YouTube videos one video
short of the one that was gonna turn so
this is there is no there's no linear
answer or binary answer to this but I do
think that when it makes sense to me
that that happened for you thank you um
okay so you have the ten thousand video
and the eighth one so you're like okay
now there's something here well so that
no not even then to your point I'm not
the product of a viral video and there
are a lot of creators that are I'm not
every video I've made has counted slowly
it's chipped away slowly it's gained but
you agree with me as also somebody who
never had a I still don't have really
that many more if any viral video so
what does that even mean but I think you
agree with me that you know there is no
long-term product of a viral video
there's just people that make viral
videos and by the way there are people
who make viral videos and then are
similar to you and I and that's the
starting point and they go on because
they have the skill set to build
something meaningful and there are tons
of people who have viral videos never to
be seen again
hundred percent it's a viral the the
concept of going viral is very short
term you know it's very war what number
video got to a million views well what
was that I don't even remember because
it was pretty deep in it was probably
your year - and that's the thing did you
[ __ ] what are you like well I bought and
finally yes I know that but in the
metaphorically way of like comic
sited I was thrilled but I'm also just I
have that immigrant mentality of my
parents that's like don't ever get too
excited about stuff keep working keep
hustling so even though it had a million
views I was like well this is not me
this is because of this trend I know
it's because of this trend of the stuff
girls say in that moment that YouTube
was having so I was probably the last
person in my life to really have that
Eureka moment of wait this could
actually go somewhere I had hit a
million subscribers I have been
traveling to different parts of the
world to perform and even still I
perform in what form um a little bit of
stand-up or a little just like fan Q&A
stuff online sometimes I would rap just
a bunch of different stuff still being
creative but still being creative um and
I still was like no this could go all go
away this doesn't mean anything it took
me a really long time to really accept
this could be a career entertainment
could be a career are you similar to me
were which I have a lot of immigrant
framework where where it wasn't as
binary as the way you said it meaning
you didn't go all the way in
but of course there was a sub or
conscious part of you that also knew
like okay this is happy things are happy
it's kind of how I feel right now like
mmm I don't feel like I feel that right
now like with all the good things that
are happening I'm like I'm not I come
you know what I'm a nerd this line
because I do that's what I'm even going
all-in like I know when I started doing
YouTube videos I didn't have a back-up
plan and I was very I believe I was very
much so like if you have a back-up plan
you're putting a little bit and hope no
matter how small energy into that
solution where really I want to focus it
is it true that you equally right now
think it can disappear and equally think
you're gonna be the biggest star in the
world 100 I totally understand yeah I
Teeter that line all the time when like
I don't need no backup plan a pretty
much it's all in you know what it is
it's balanced I think that's what I have
to I think it's actually when we think
we have balance or lack of balance I
think we have balance I think the
extreme worst person in my entire life
that has ever told me I think you're
balanced thank you I think that our
balance is pulling harder in the
opposite directions than most people I
guess in this regard I have balance in
other facets of my life perhaps not but
in this regard yeah sure yeah because
that's the best part guys ever I I have
enormous balance in human life I'm
completely imbalanced when it comes to
being a sports fan
I'm actually sitting here conducting
this interview with you operating this
enormous business because we just had a
pretty important meeting and I'm one
right behind it and the only thing I'm
thinking about is that I want to punch
Baker Mayfield in the [ __ ] face
because the Jets are playing the Browns
tonight and half my team is hurt and I'm
an actual tilt right now I feel safe
good so so anyway I actually think
you're balanced I fully understand that
yeah okay now tell me about let's go
even further back yeah actually let me
stay on this because I think it brings
more value to the audience the YouTube
thinks happening you're doing these
performance things real quick just
because I think it's an important topic
where were you in balancing out your
platforms for creativity and awareness
you know one of things I think is super
interesting is people becoming
one-dimensional on the platform that
feeds them as you're growing when did
you hit a million or when did you feel
like you were really in a big moment on
YouTube twelve fourteen just give me
like a rough lick what year probably
2014 was okay so were you also actively
at that point being like active on
Twitter or Instagram or pod Kenny thing
else were you rounding out the platform
yes I've always been a big how I used to
view things with everything is a funnel
to youtube that's how I used to maybe I
don't necessarily view it like that -
yeah it's very now it's about certain
content lives in certain places and each
of the contexts
casimir exactly that wasn't the case in
2000 under stand yet 2014 was a YouTube
is paying me YouTube is where I get my
bread and butter everyone obviously now
it's that's not a good strategy because
other social media platforms they all
hate each other so you can't even drive
people correctly from one platform to
another but now I find it important to
know Twitter's for my tweets my thoughts
my etc it doesn't have to continuously
drive to youtube it's more about these
minikin were you most going to bring
down me right now I'm probably most
active on Instagram okay yeah what else
is in your repertoire anything yes so I
still do YouTube I saw I had a
regimented YouTube schedule for eight
years that is insane it was too scripted
videos a week plus seven vlogs so nine
videos a week I did that for eight years
I just stopped that at the top of this
year because I was going crazy
announced it I announced the top of this
year in January like cold why do social
media you know the thing that we all do
I took a break up social media in
November took a little bit of time to
sit on my thoughts and feelings and then
in January I noticed you know what's so
funny I had you you said you just said
something you said you know how we all
do and I never have and then I but it's
interesting
I literally for the first time ever came
up with this idea I've been debating I'm
shocked I'm saying this out loud cuz
it's so early and I don't tend to share
my thoughts this early but young people
you really inspire me I've been thinking
about creating something called
disappearing December ooh where I'm
completely him disappear for a whole
month of December no content I love that
for you and I was like huh and then you
know and where it went it was like you
know I might want to everyone here my
whole team was like are we fired it's
really interesting
there's something about Jan one that is
always sat with me mhm uh December's
interesting because you know there's
some family time
I'm usually pissed about football I
always get a little inspired about my
family but you know I grew up in my
dad's family liquor store so the wine
stores always got a little my attention
veiners quite busy I want to see Pete
like it's a very interesting night for
all of us it's an interesting month and
I was like wow like you know I wonder
you know it's kind of like move member
like the whole like that whole thing
like I was like huh I wonder if I do
this wonder how many people will do it
wonder what that means I think humans
take scheduling very serious mm-hmm
there's almost a part of me that
believes that if if people disappear in
December that they're January and
they're new year starts off better when
I completely agree so I'm debating it I
am all in please let me know if this
goes down cuz I will disappear in
December as well see this is what see
this is what scares me about this is I
really think it's smart and I actually
think it would be adopted and scale and
I think that now I'm questioning myself
of like is the only reason I want to do
this because I think it's gonna become
here right right and I want to be like
I'm the [ __ ] the creek you know I'm
trying to like figure it out
if I'm like doing it because I know it
will try to see if you're break from
validate
online will result in you being
validated actually you know how we think
about life like right before I die I
like I think when you're creative and
then it's took me a long time only I've
only decided hmm to accept like oh wait
a minute maybe I'm creative in the last
couple years cuz it was like I'm a
businessman um no it's actually just cuz
I like being associated with ideas
that's great like I just like the idea
this is it's actually this simple uh
nine years from now going through the
airport and hearing a mom and daughter
walking be like well we've got
disappearing December coming up anyway
and so just to think like I [ __ ] a
mom with that as a matter of fact I just
realized what I'm doing now in the meta
I just put it out before somebody else
stumbles on it now I've got this boom
boom put a trademark oh by the way
honestly without you know everyone's
like trademark and all this stuff I
never do those things this already feels
good anyway I'm sorry nonetheless so so
what about as a kid where were you born
and how did you grow up I was born in
Toronto Canada okay I only moved from
Toronto five years ago to LA I was very
Raptors fan oh yeah oh the NBA champs
yes I'm fans of the NBA Jeff but are you
a [ __ ] Raptors no no I've been so I
really I couldn't tell me a lot about
Vince Carter
this was about to say I've been a really
diehard fans of past probably said six
seven years so not when I was super
young my family wasn't very into sports
my family was into making ends meet we
didn't have to immigrant parents that
are from India from India Punjab
so that we're going back to that
immigrant hustles embedded in me of
course I have an older sister which is
very interesting in full circle because
for so much of my life my parents wanted
me to follow her footsteps ourse of
course did the psych degree at all
things I get it now she does YouTube
she's older just six years older than me
so that's been an interesting
full-circle moment of course growing up
I was a huge tomboy loved to be
rebellious in the most ridiculous of
things like painting my room red would
go to the end of the earth to do these
ridiculous things that my parents for
some reason because her Indian would
always oppose even though makes no sense
of course um and I just really loved
being creative you know I loved dancing
I was a dancer for a good part of my
life hugger dancing which is like
traditional Indian dance
this one brown guy in the room is
nodding his head at me yep and I was
just always that kid my parents just
kind of learned very early that if Lilly
really wants to do something she is
going to do it regardless of what we say
that's always fun and even with dancing
you know traditionally my parents didn't
like that they didn't like me performing
it doesn't sound like a doctor or
engineer so I had children a year for me
to convince them and how I convinced
them wasn't through lying it wasn't
there sneaking out my house to go to
dance practice it was hey you're gonna
come to my next show and you're gonna
see what I do it's always been educating
my parents on what I want to do because
I believe so strongly that it's valuable
of course same with YouTube you know
when I told my parents I want to make
youtube videos and not go to grad school
my parents like what first of all what
are you talking about we don't know
whose YouTube yeah so but they you know
said you have a year to try to figure it
out and you know 20 I have immigrant
parents as well and like I went into a
family business and the number one
question I get asked is like how did you
how do you convince your dad to let you
do things right I get so many emails
from men and women who asked about their
mom and dad's business and they can't do
things and no matter how much I did at
14 and I worked every [ __ ] weekend
and holiday no matter how much talent I
showed and results from 14 to 22 and in
my own mind I took it it still required
my dad saying micro yeses when I was
like hey let's buy this weird sparkling
papaya juice I'll never forget this I
bought a bunch of like sparkling
non-alcoholic juice that had this was
1991 and the flavors were mango and pear
and papaya like people came in the store
like what's a mango like like you know
like like and and we sold it all and I
always think of like that being a moment
where I convinced my dad who I was but
it still took the micro yes for it you
know a lot of dads and moms say no to
the mango juice sure and so a dad thank
you for saying yes to the mango juice
and be hearing your parents having you
know we're lucky as strict and old
schools our parents were they had micro
yeses in that for sure letting you have
the year to prove it I never say buying
the mango juice
a lot of kids don't have that and I'm
very grateful percent and another thing
I tell cuz I get a lot of the similar
question sort of people saying I want to
do yeah and I always this might not be
the answer people want to hear but for
me at least my experience was true my
parents became fine with my career once
they knew I was going to be ok I think
for Indian parent or any immigrant
parents it's more so we don't care about
what your passion is we don't care about
any of that we want to know that when
we're dead and gone will you be family I
think this is my biggest passion life we
need to convince [ __ ] human beings
that ok is happy not have some money
mm-hmm no 100% a period a period do you
do anything miserable is [ __ ] doctors
and engineers from a monster are
listening right now no miserable is [ __ ]
and we know that but I think for my
parents
he didn't matter I get happy something
would not get it was are you going to be
able to I can't --have of course because
they came from place I mean look I know
where our parents came from but we as
stewards to this like and and everybody
in our society today we have to change
ok not for we're make you're making
money on your tick-tock videos it's I'm
happy to make tick-tock videos and I'm
willing to live a $40,000 a year
lifestyle to do that that happiness has
to start pushing against money way back
to that one another question I get often
is I want to start making YouTube videos
you have me advice and ice oh when a
device is always do something you care
about talk about something you care
about make videos about something that
matters to you because the fame and the
numbers and the money is not gonna
fulfill you the way having a point of
view that you care about is I agree like
Katie do we have questions ok before we
get into that so the manager calls yet
you're wearing your half blazer half
sweat suit it was a ballgown yeah and
you change the story and you're sitting
there yeah over this month of doing
research to give an answer to these
white executives yep when it finally
came into your head like you [ __ ] this
is gonna happen yeah because you decided
for yourself it's gonna happen who were
the top people you want it to be guests
on the show there was some point right
after you did this you're like okay I'm
in a first week
my first show so I had a mix I have two
buckets of people in the first bucket is
Beyonce because once I have Beyonce on
my show I can retire and not do anything
else ever issues with the second bucket
honestly I know you listen every day I
never so you just hit her up and the
second bucket of people is people that
have not yet had an opportunity to be on
late-night or not having like a lot of
my friends or people who I've just
admired online who have never had a
chance
I remember Fallon absolutely was the
burkas gabon person the producer came
from diggnation and remember there was a
little bit of that not to the level that
I think you're about to embark on I mean
it's cool every facet of my show whether
it's the writers room or like people the
script assist or whatever I'm really
trying to infiltrate it with people that
I know could use this opportunity it's
cool because that's the actual legacy of
the show on air great though the 22
minutes you see on screen great it's fun
it's cute whatever but it's actually
giving people awkward what's the format
gonna be so you change the name right
which Alice thank you I like that um
it's you know the staples of late-night
that were either we love and we're used
to so the monologue the sketch etc but
I'm making it a lot more personal
because I'm prioritizing community
building which I don't think the
late-night world has done yet me coming
from the YouTube world I know the value
of the community yep and so my
monologues are not just template
monologues anyone can read they're very
much so based in my experience is Who I
am
the audience will get to know me beyond
just the host of the show they'll get to
know Lily the type of person she is what
her moral compass is or experience etc
what's the punch line with that time
slot you know is you know obviously
there's the history in Carson to have
such a before we went on there ordering
the air like 70 what a run 79 years did
such a great job but you know I go into
cliche common sense and I'm like ooh
like you know interest like young dudes
like that stay up to 130 is one place I
go people that lived alternative lives
were like you know working at those
times or things of that nature and then
I'm just thinking about the nature of
like for example I we were very similar
obviously we came up the same way I also
have really never debated having a show
was offer something the closest I like
the big moment for me someone to you and
I was just too deep into this was you
know a syndicated show which is even 200
gun
day time and I really wanted to because
I wanted but just too much nonetheless I
I'm very curious about how much of this
show is consumed online days later clips
I'm sure knowing your DNA like it'll be
really interesting to see for me for me
how I'm viewing it is that one 3 a.m. it
launches and it starts its life beyond
that I'm not married to the idea people
are viewing it i 1:30 we're well aware
majority of people will view it the next
day on youtube and for me i actually and
is that how it works just for
functionality like the full show will be
on youtube the next will be divided into
clips but when those clips are combined
combined yes it's all parts of the show
got it
and that's a joke you're like a hard
hardcore fan yeah so [ __ ] is like i love
the show and like he could go watch 5
clips and bases and see every piece of
the show - like a couple seconds of like
dead air time yes you'd be undersea
every element of the show and it's
important for me because commercial
world i have a worldwide audience you
know not everyone has to NBC yeah so
it's important for me for them cool
consume it yeah awesome thanks some
questions let's do it let's call some
peeps oh yeah
and these historically DVR been a big
play for these Late Late shows do you
know sure I don't I'm not now with you -
I don't know I feel like it's just due
to nikita nikita koloff was my favorite
wrestler you're gonna get are gonna get
a whole bunch of brown people calling in
right now i love it Nikita this could be
a Russian [ __ ] gangster or it could
be somebody who's not gonna answer and
be devastated that's what I was living
for these are always my favorite memes
when I scold people please leave your
message four five one zero nine zero
here we go we don't have anything
everybody can figure out Nikita it's
Gary and Lily this is one of the great
mistakes of your life you're not picking
up the phone you will probably do what
everybody else does which is you're
gonna call back however we are not going
to pick up the phone because life is
about timing and this is a lesson that I
want to teach the audience have a great
day Lily Nikita
have a great day after this message I'm
still rooting for you
I'd love to talk to you one day Nikita
I'm [ __ ] rooting for you too I'm just
talking about timing matters in life
sweet me don't let this be the thing
that ruins our day this won't ruin your
day this is like a funny meme Nikita you
can watch this video all the time I
always think about timing I always think
about the meaning I didn't take mmm-hmm
that is absolutely the one that would
have changed the course of my career I
look I loved timing I think Jamie yeah
this is Gary Vaynerchuk and you're on
Lily hey oh my god I'm gonna cry crying
you're good
sure cry fine but speak - okay okay I'm
pulling at my blog camera Lily hi hi so
I am 25 years old I'm a dancer in Miami
I had watched all of your videos all of
your vlogs and like we spoke about your
depression like not the person but the
funk that you once you're on the break
that you took um and I watched and kind
of lived all of that with you because
like that's the same exact thing that
I've been going through so I understood
like through the videos that you were
dealing with burnout um so I'm 25 now
and I've owned a gym and a dance video
here in Miami since I was 19 but
certainly just feel burnt out um so I
guess my question is like how do you
overcome that and like I just feel you
know what I mean yeah great question
yeah there's a great question so I took
a social media break at the end of last
year and you know there's a lot of
things that helped me but one thing in
particular that I found so helpful was
redefining how I how I define self-care
basically I think previously in my life
I used to work so tremendously hard and
so relentlessly hard as you know if you
watched all of my videos you know
there's a lot of them I used to work so
tremendously hard and my idea of a break
would be once a year I'd go to a resort
and get drunk and eat a lot of food and
then go back to my life and then work
relentlessly harms amazing so that
there's that sound amazing but it's not
sustainable I've learned that self-care
is nothing is sustainable really
actually let me rephrase like like what
keep going I'm gonna let you finish
one thing that well what I've learned is
that you know for me self-care is small
things everyday really it's about 10
minutes of meditation I do every day
it's about writing my diary if I feel
clouded it's about going on a walk if I
need to and that and that actually makes
me work smarter and work better than
when I'm working from morning tonight
non-stop I actually get a lot more done
when I'm a happy healthy person because
I've dedicated 20 minutes of my day to
just being a human if it makes any sense
and Jamie - Jamie to add to that you
know what is not sustainable is micro
tactics so you know I already already
have friends that are on the other side
of meditation like it's just an emerging
thing and you've already getting
hundreds of DMS and texts and emails and
conversations around I have been doing
it for three years and it's worn out its
value which is actually where I want to
take this - the little micro
conversation Lily and I just had nothing
sustainable wait wait a minute yes it is
it I think something that you need to
give a lot of thought to is judgment so
one of the things that and even by your
reaction it excites me I'm super
passionate about judgment a the way we
judge ourselves be the way we allow
other people's judgments to become a
variable in our lives when I think about
the only sustainable thing that I have
in me and I give a huge shout out to Tom
Bell you when he was on my podcast and
actually giving this to me because I was
living it I just didn't put words to it
my ability to not judge myself which
then leads me to not judging others has
been the greatest gift of my life and is
the only sustainable thing I have
through all my twists and turns my
friend for you to be a 25 and already
have this much accomplishment under your
belt I like I'm gonna cry oh my god I
care I really need you to see this and
it makes me happy that you're that we're
having this micro talk like brother like
listen like you've guys like you're
beating yourself up or allowing somebody
else to beat you up when you've already
had in you can add a whole lot so I
think that you just kind of hit the nail
in the coffin was me Gary
so like judgment is a really big thing
which is why I've always been a try
that's you Lily because she's never been
afraid to be herself which has done her
where she is today which is launching
her it's amazing
so like I'm here in Miami I'm a six foot
three black man that dances for a living
so yeah but come up to me every single
day and ask me if I'm an athlete yes and
then I have to say no I'm a dancer so
like even within myself I'm so afraid of
my own craft and being judged and even
things like opening up the YouTube
channel I've been so afraid of my own
judgement and then people's judge
Jimmy Jimmy and let's stay on this
because this is gonna be very valuable
for this has the potential be very very
valuable for a lot of people so let's
keep playing the three of us yeah a
couple things I don't know Lily well
enough but I was listening to a couple
things
Lily's serendipity of being an immigrant
to a parent structure that I'm familiar
with and and her having the DNA from a
very young age to fight the system and
be comfortable with the ramifications
similar to me got us into a place where
no and and being on an island and not
looking for acceptance but having
conviction to the inner conversation led
us to a lot of practice by the time we
got older so many of us maybe you maybe
not I'm just painting a picture here so
many people don't practice from 0 to 22
of being comfortable in know they have
their entire energy to chasing yes to
looking for acceptance from others so
what what may be happening to you when I
hear that from you where I go is like
okay awesome I'm so [ __ ] happy how
life works we're gonna stick on this
moment we're not going to the next call
because all I want Jamie for you to
understand is the following other
people's judgement is such a tell to
what's going on in their lives
you can never control look you will
never be able to control it so it's
check this thing always in your control
Jamie I when I look at people hating
other people and this is not a joke and
this is not the most popular opinion
when I watch other people hate or overly
judge or try to make you know hate you
know I'm not going to racism I'm even
talking about being in a meeting
watching somebody roll their eyes so
that person sees it to their idea
because they're trying to impose their
sadness within them on somebody out
misery loves company is something is
something that I think right now
intuitively needs a bigger platform in
conversation in our society because for
some reason I really understand it and
so if you leave this call with nothing
other than anybody that casts judgment
on you that you should deploy empathy
and sympathy for them because they're
dealing with their own [ __ ] can really
change the diagram for you my friend
I've never met a happy successful person
that had something unnecessarily mean or
bad to say about someone else so I feel
like when you are in a good place in
your life like I always think about this
when I received negative comments online
I mean ever knew for so many years but I
still you know people say you have thick
skin there'll be a comment or two that
still gets your everybody Minh everybody
I always think what the fact that when
I'm in a good place I don't wake up and
I don't have the desire to write mean
things about people on the internet and
so really the type of person that is
doing it is someone that is not happy
and not in a good place so I absolutely
agree with your sentiment Gary and it's
also just goes back to control for me
it's I know I can control my reaction to
things I can control my thought process
I can I'll never be able to control
someone else and with it really I swear
on everything that I hold dear that when
I see the negative comments which I get
every single day and I read comments cuz
that's how I do research I said I
genuinely sit there and I'm like I feel
so bad there's Mary it is as foreign to
me as to commit murder right now I'm
being dead serious right now at the
thought of killing another human is as
foreign to me as going to somebody's
social media profile consuming their
content and then leaving something
negative
I completely agree that's why I just
know that it's someone that's not in a
good place
Jamie listen even let me tell you
something about your youth one thing I
push a lot is perspective on time you
were gonna live literally three more
full lives everything you've done from
the day you were born to right now
you're about to be three more times yeah
it is really crazy
especially when you're ambitious and
trying to create something and being in
a one of the ten biggest cities where
there's a lot of action going on you
know what's everybody else doing
if you contextualize that that will help
you so much as well because let me tell
you what I believe I believe for a lot
of us a lot of us for all different
reasons create a framework where we
allow outside opinion to have a
disproportionate impact on our lives a
disproportionate and if we were born
into anything that even looks remotely
different than the norm we immediately
are on our back foot immigrant you know
gender sex preferences skin totally and
by the way let me let me say this for
the small group of white men that aren't
immigrants that born in America they
have their insecurities to because their
mom tells them they're not as smart as
their brother not as sore ass this is
this this human condition is for
everyone for everyone right and so what
you need to do off this call and if you
understood the math behind even being
the person that we got to write and by
the way yeah Nikita Nikita could have
answered it brought up a great question
and we would have never gotten to you
right Jane you have to understand that
what you have to start doing right now
is getting quiet within your own head
but Jimmy let me tell you one part that
nobody talks about that might help you
write part of the equation of getting
quiet is also not getting too high when
people say that you're brilliant right
one of the reasons I've noticed so much
insecurity I'm like wait a minute they
take in that they're beautiful or
they're fast or they throw the ball hard
or they're clever or they're good at
great one of the things that it's why
this is so full circle why I think
you're balanced is because you think
you're gonna be the biggest and you
think you're no one I understand that
too and that's no different than not
getting too high when everybody says
you're great I'm a big believer of this
too and it goes
Gault's comes down to not taking
anything personally whether it's
positive or negative act because you
can't sit there and be like I'm not
gonna take negativity personally but I'm
gonna accept all this praise it really
has to be from both ends you know when
someone comes up to me as many people
doing I'm trigger you have this a lot
people will come up to you and say you
changed my life and I always say I
didn't read that you did you change your
life perhaps I was part of your world
I've never much better than I'm like I'm
not completely completely the reason
your life is changed I agree but it goes
back just not taking either of those
things personally and I know it sounds
kind of absurd because you you think you
should be taking in positive energy not
negative but I think what you can't pick
and choose right you can't take and
beautiful and not Jamie what other weird
little thing I think you should go and
volunteer one day for a retirement home
Wow okay
I'll tell you why I feel like people
that are in this position need massive
perspective injects right we're having
this awesome talk you're gonna take the
high of this you're gonna build a little
bit I'm telling you right now there's
nothing that can help people more than
going to somebody who they don't know
not your grandparent and spending a day
with people in their 90's and
understanding how all the things of
people rolling up on you in the Miami
scene and casting judgment means
jack-shit
and that perspective is everything
you've got to start the process off this
phone call to detach from judgment both
pro and con that is the roundup also the
last I'm going to say to you as someone
who also Dan says anyone that says
you're not nasty because you dance is
wrong dance is so extreme no of course
it is amazing so of course be proud of
that be proud of that as a fellow dancer
it's not to throw that in there Jamie
instead of letting you go and having
this feel-good good moment what have you
like I'm just really curious like what's
running through your mind right now for
real for real more importantly not a
good
not the good but the part that you're
leaving when you hang up here where
you're like yeah yeah but I want to
really know what's in your head as yeah
but Jamie so can I say three things you
could take seven three things that are
on my mind so number one Lily
you said that to get out of your funk
you do something like take a vacation
you Bob
so like I feel even worse because like I
just did that so like I'm trying to
start a modeling career on top of the
fitness business that are running in
Miami so I just went to Italy for 10
days to like clear my mind in vacation
but then you come back and you're like
oh wait I spoke on all this to do and I
gotta figure out how I'm gonna get it
done so like for me I feel like I've
done the vacation card I'd even like
packed up all my stuff moved to a
different city because I was just over
the fitness industry here and I've come
back and people support me all the same
so like for me I don't I don't know how
to get out of the funk because I've done
the the rest part of it like the rest
your mind part now it's just like crap
how do I build a bigger business on top
of this number - Gary you said like
quiet and like silence Tom man so like
social media really drives me crazy
because I watched your videos Gary and
you say to coat post post post content
content content and for me that is the
hardest thing to do because I'm a bit
I'm a personality but like I hate to
post on social media like even my social
now you hate to post on social media
because overvalue the opinions you're
not in a mindset of creation you're in a
mindset of validation and speaking of
validation I just came up with a thing
called disappearing December which
really let's go back to that point real
quick
like literally 99% of people online are
in the mindset of validation the reason
I say post post post is I want you to be
in a mindset of creation I want you to
do it for you Jamie you probably aren't
watching my content enough to know that
I reference four times seven times a
year that seemed from Rocky for where
Drago loses to Rocky and he yells at the
Soviet Union and all the people in a
crown he said [ __ ] you guys this was an
America versus the USSR I was in this
ring for me and that's like what I want
to inject a little Drago into everybody
I want you to post for you not for the
likes not for the validation for the
mindset of creating and leaving your two
cents on the world for you the reason
nobody wants to post is it's become one
big game of insecurities
and the third thing is just like so Gary
um
I kind of jumped into you when I was 19
and 20 because I got sponsored by one of
the biggest universities here in Miami
FIU so like they built my very first gym
for me at one hundred and twenty
thousand dollars at 19 years old Wow and
it was the craziest experience and like
I've been dancing for the past six years
and just doing what I love every day but
for me now the business side it's like
damn I get burnt out so easily and so
quickly when you realize oh crap no
one's paying my bills I'm the only one
doing this and like every move I make is
my next paycheck
you know and like growing this so I
guess these are all the stocks that are
just like I it's hard to feel added up
in like different areas of your life no
listen I talk about self-awareness over
everything that is my biggest religion
rather there is nothing wrong with you
not being an entrepreneur and owner of
this thing if you know I I have had my
family's livelihood then I had to start
from zero again cuz I built it for my
family
there's oh I can go on and on and I've
never felt a fear of the next paycheck
because I'm in my zone if I had to read
a script if I had Lily's job and I don't
know how you're doing it but if I had to
read from a teleprompter tonight in
front of zero people I would I would be
so [ __ ] scared because I can't read
for [ __ ] and it's an insecurity of mine
but if I have to go give an impromptu
keynote right now in Madison Square
Garden in front of 37,000 people and I
could talk about my [ __ ] I would
moonwalk to the garden right now you you
might be you just might not need to be
an owner of a gym which is amazing and
that's and by the way let me really play
this out cuz I'm [ __ ] fully invested
at this point I appreciate it and let me
let me give you the piece that I think
really matters because I think you kind
of might know what I just said and the
part of me losing the gym and having
your auntie or your best friend or your
neighbor or somebody that ripped up to
you that's doing well right now judge
you means horse [ __ ] to the amount of
people that judge people that are doing
from the sidelines
makes me laugh when you're judged for
closing the gym because you're deploying
self-awareness to happiness and you get
a comment of ossie and maybe you put
yourself out there maybe you made a
video three years ago and said I'm gonna
crush and build the next gold gym and
maybe you could put yourself in that
spot it still doesn't matter because
you're doing and living it doesn't
matter what they think of that and and
just to go back to your first point
Jamie I want to emphasize how you viewed
that vacation line is exactly how I used
to view for the many many years of my
life what I highly recommend is that I'm
saying you don't need to do that I'm
saying that let's take ten minutes today
after this call even to just reflect
meditate right I'm saying that if you're
not having fun on the journey it's like
not worth it and this is someone who's
worked relentlessly hard if you've
watched my flows you know this I know
you I I believe in working hard even
still but the thing I believe in most is
you have to be happy I had this woman so
much I couldn't believe in this more
Jamie 99% of people just came back from
summer vacation and the first [ __ ]
day back all the things that they
thought they got went in the garbage by
9:48 p.m. mm-hmm no hey you know and so
like and so like I really really really
think that it is a much more macro thing
this comes down to judgment if there was
nobody else on earth everybody would be
happy
amen I'm telling you this is a judgment
game mm-hmm this is you worried about
what people are gonna think once I got
to the final pieces of not even caring
what my own parents thought fully it
completely unlocked for me and I was
already ridiculously happy you can't let
judgment seep in it is the poison and to
that point you know we just said the
parents lied a lot of times when we let
go of those types of ideas a little well
of course my parents have to judge me my
friends when you let go of all then you
get the judgment to yourself because you
think oh that makes me a bad son or a
bad daughter you have to also not judge
yourself in that regard so it's just let
me give you a secret to all the kids out
there who are struggling with not
letting their parents down because I get
that all day long Gary you say well you
put all this pressure on the parenting
dynamic I always say to them listen
net-net and this is not a blanket
statement nothing can be a blanket
statement but I genuinely believe that
every kid
who decides to do what their parents
want them to do versus what they want to
do end up 30 years later 26 years later
41 years later in massive underlining
subconscious resentment of their parents
and I would rather kids and parents have
a shitty three to five years then have a
life a life full of resentment and
undertones and all that anxiety and
guess what happens out of that three to
five years of bad somebody ends up being
right and you don't even need to have
right first of all take it from two
people parents get real proud when when
they're not sure and then you do it sure
that's the ultimate for a parent and
more importantly a lot of times kids
lose - there's a lot of kids that told
their parents they were gonna be the
biggest rapper in the world went to LA
and nine years later are not the biggest
rapper in the world and they come back
to Kansas and they get a job in the
family business or within the profession
or something else and guess what their
parents are thrilled they're back home
because they missed them and guess what
else that next Eminem or next jay-z also
feels good or next meghna stallion they
also feel good cuz they gave it a
[ __ ] shot mhm and now that they're a
carpenter or a businesswoman or whatever
the hell they're doing they don't have
to live with regret this is why we have
to push this narrative because it will
lead to more happiness for sure everyone
agree Jamie how you feelin I'm like
shaking I'm like shaking I have like a
vlog camera in front of me because I'm
like crying and I'm like wiping my face
get that thumb nobu get that thumb to
Jamie which person in your life opinion
do you value the most who do you think
is really riding real mindset that like
when you think about your life and you
think about when the gym open who you
called or whose validation do you
genuinely believe you're anchoring - um
it's definitely mom and I think again
we're all immigrants or like I was born
in Jamaica and mom is now a doctor so
like I'm mom learned very early like
James not gonna be a doctor like I was
at school for acting and dance like he
immediately picked up on that
definitely think it's her validation
even though she's come to terms just
like hey my kid is a performer like he's
not she's not following my line of work
you know but again you want to make her
proud and like somehow like hey mom like
everything that I'm doing and like all
the time I'm wasting in this industry
it's not for nothing you know Jamie
comes on that and I apologize for not
letting you go but I just feel like
you're you're ours now you're you're
you're doing so much good for so many
people right now and I'm not gonna let
it go even though I feel the stress of
my team telling me I'm late and it's a
nap Jamie listen to me we have to change
the narrative of artists or
entrepreneurs or athletes or creative
people or anybody who's willing to have
any conviction of their own happiness
for that matter you're not wasting your
time we have to put the process on a
pedestal not the results that come with
it absolutely I promise you this there
are a ton of mothers and fathers who are
listening right now who are devastated
that their kids went through a process
of making them proud they achieved
everything they got the degree they got
the business they got the money and now
they're 48 and they just had dinner last
week and they're completely broken and
you're you you can't put that judgment
on yourself your mother and every mother
and father deep down even if they don't
realize it they're number one crowd
moment is if their child is happy if
their child had enough conviction to
make themselves happy if you could get
happy about the process of this versus
whatever results this Jim does you will
be in a much better happy place where
did your mom send currently on this like
she's scared and worried disappointed
pumped um Elaine oh so like you and
again I'll make it faster that so I
basically already went to the process of
like closing the gym because I knew that
it wasn't gonna work I moved away I came
back and now what I've done is like
infiltrated in other gyms so that I'm
not being a huge overhead and taking all
my classes there so momma was really
proud because like I'm running things
than her I have more time on my hands so
so mom is proud mom just wants to see me
reach the level that she that she knows
I can you know
but you know what you and Mom have to
have a conversation about that because
that's an arbitrary number that's a
that's a fake thing that's like
vaynermedia when people like your
creative needs to be better I'm like no
no your judgment on this video is the
judge is the king and queen right like
like you have to have a cup
I'm telling you Jaime you have to have a
conversation with your mom about that
reaching your full potential or what
you're capable of has to be on your
happiness state right now you're nowhere
on that I don't give a [ __ ] how many
classes you're doing in 97 ships and
your profit margins better it needs to
be on being happy about your day to day
a man agreed yes sir you know what I
mean it also sounds like compared to a
lot of situations other people are in
having a mom in this position is great
not gonna mean it's amazing so I think
all the pieces to make make things pop
off here just I I agree have that
conversation and don't do the but after
this as Gary mentioned Jamie the key the
key is knowing how to quantify ambition
so it doesn't manifest in your own
personal judgment and anxiety I'm I'm so
uncomfortably ambitious but I've got
lucky and circumstantial to put it into
a place that doesn't cache judgment if
you know in a world where I've been very
successful business wise in the last 20
years but between the partnership with
my dad and a partnership with my brother
I have nowhere close to the personal
finances needed to achieve my
professional goals of buying the New
York Jets at 43 years old I sit here
cool as a cucumber so you can imagine
why I push patience and lack of judgment
on 25 year olds absolutely absolutely
sir
don't listen please change behavior past
this please take this phone call as a
moment in your life to change your
behavior and recalibrate the
conversation the ambition needs to be
waking up happy not anything else
absolutely Gary can I just say that like
I this is a promise that I'm making to
you because I watched your show almost
weekly and to be rather frank like I was
about to take a shower go to work and
like go train a client and then I opened
facebook and I fell
Lily on your show I freaked because you
guys you are the only two people that I
watch when I'm in a funk so like Lily
like again I watched her in a funk
earlier this year and I'm watching her
start her own show which is like it's
the craziest thing so like if I'm seeing
someone like her who I've watched for
six seven years do it and get out of it
like this call is the biggest wake-up
call to me for like please please thank
you Jamie
like you Jamie this is how we're gonna
end this call I think I don't want the
lily in a spot but I think I'm four - I
think there's a very strong likelihood
or maybe even booked they're kind of
almost booked like I'm gonna be on
Lily's show oh yes 100% okay I just
didn't I felt like we were there so
Jamie I'm I'm going to fly you up here
and we're gonna hang out with me in the
green room the day I do the show no I'll
give you your own green room it'll be
bigger than Gary's and then he can check
check hang in your green room by the way
Janie and you know like that works for
me when you're green rooms bigger than
mine what Lily doesn't know is she just
gave me a real Mitzvah because that's
gonna motivate me even more to be the
greatest [ __ ] guest on her show ever
premiering tonight at 10 p.m. on YouTube
so so Jamie I'm gonna have Katie give
you a call and get all your details and
once we're locked in
you'll come into New York City you're
gonna hang out at Vayner in the morning
we're gonna help look at your stuff then
we're gonna all go in to record the show
la I'm an idiot we're gonna put you're
gonna I'm gonna fly to LA you're gonna
fly down this is what's fun about being
global you're gonna fly to LA I'm gonna
meet you in the LA office of Vayner
we're gonna hang out then we're gonna go
do the show you're gonna hang out in
your bigger green room I'll come and
visit and then after the show all three
of us can talk about all the things you
want to talk about I just that's firm
that is now where you want to buy you a
yacht and burn it to the ground in your
face to motivate you
Jamie we'll see you soon
thank you better start crying you're
coming to LA to see you see you Jamie
bye thank you look at Mon look at you
make look at us you you you I'm just
texting my Booker right now say we need
to get Kenny we're already working on it
thank you thank you this was a lot of a
great conversation there really was some
I really wish you nothing but success
please vaynernation support this show
getting off to a big start on these kind
of shows unfortunately really matters
it's just the difference of YouTube
versus network TV the the
infrastructures on TV I'm sure she has a
long rope and they wouldn't sign her up
but it never hurts and I think an extra
push matters and so please tonight if
you find yourself up and about
especially because I know a lot of your
hardcore up at 1:30 a little social love
for the episode any any little bill will
help her and as you can tell as she was
talking there's so much that I agree
with this wonderful woman on and more of
this conversation needs to see the earth
and so I am rooting for her heavy and
anything you guys can do for her would
mean a lot to me thank you thank you so
much Gary and thank you differen
listening